tu peux tout mais les gars on a voulu
faire croire que c'était son habitat
naturel
juste un jardin par exemple
[Musique]
ces castings déjà il est badass ya plein
il ya plein de copains il ya un évier
poupe du golden show tv nova greg et
david du palmashow antoine daniel aka a
car c'est dans notre coeur et qu'on
voulait absolument voir bruce banner et
surtout quand il paye ses fesses eu
l'occasion d'être à poil sur le toit du
grand rex et de m'exposer tout paraît
donc ça fait c'est très bien on merci
beaucoup je sélectionnerais le masne
directeur du grand rex qui nous a
autorisés à tourner en audio du mois je
vous l avez le plus vu de paris que j'ai
vu pour l'instant côté 1 300 plein
centre ville attend place en de
pareilles talent à vue sur tout paris et
c'est surtout intéressant de risquer ma
vie en fait juste pour ça quoi là c'est
le vide les fous tu peux te citer nos
souvenirs se plaît parce que là c'est
flou non rien du tout wendigo il faut
qu'il nous a appelé pour savoir si on
voulait jouer dans le sketch la fia
partout
on a 30 ans et on peut se disant super
héros je pense que voir des matches en
retard
quelque part ça nous a plu je finisse de
musique fantastique je suis élastique
c'est pas mal parce que m gagnera donc
réaliste ce sketch dans les discussions
à base de je crois pas que la ville
pourrait être plus haut je pense alors
là en fait le truc c'est que greg va se
casser une bouteille on sucre dans ses
détails spéciale est agacé sur la tête
donc on a une seule bouteille parce que
ça coûte assez cher donc faux pas qui
sera là c'est un petit peu le stress
action
[Musique]
des sorties voilà de que d'éclairement
l'espère aussi se mettre à ce détruisent
meilleure part on a un peu l'impression
de découvrir une mine d'or tu en as
besoin mais attendez ce père héros plus
que de voir ça jamais des thèses que ce
qu'on a fait encore là je suis pas je me
souviens juste que je suis moi ça me
fait super plaisir des sens le sech
suricates
non seulement je te disais par mon père
j'ai habillé en spider man pourquoi je
suis venu en découlent y a rien
d'anormal là tu n'en es pas mortel
ferait on sait pas le flou est plutôt
s'installe story 4
ouais super tu appelles blague ya pas de
musique quel tissu vraiment 15 litres
d'eau
et encore je te laisse imaginer odeurs
on devrait inventer des heures en fait
entre 11h et 12h on devrait inventer
genre 4h04 de quatre heures de plus mais
beaucoup de gens masqués ouf c'est qu'on
a une [__] d'équipé qui nous demande
est au taquet corps et ça c'est ouf en
fait en place on fait si leur action
tu vois des gens mobilisés pour un truc
que tu as écrit également comme des
connards gars là ils vont bien ce canard
et où qu'il aille à canal canard pâques
ou pas eh bien on fait comme si j'arrive
à marc de vos biens ils vont toucher au
mac ça t'as pas un truc pour booster je
suis pas ta km sa batterie mais y avait
un adaptateur et on va sûrement incrusté
la carte de la météo
[Musique]
les photos à arcachon hop hop je passe
je passe je passe à excuse moi j'en
appelle ouais bah ouais c'est moi ça
[Musique]